yo guys prestige here and I got some
awesome news 4j Studios is released
another screenshot of the Minecraft Xbox
ition title abbr t9 let's get into it
boom so here we see the entire screen
shop it's everything we got four
quadrants of stuff to look at so I'm
going to zoom in on each and analyze
them for you guys so first time first
one we're going to look at the top left
the top left obvious things are we got
the different types of wood we have a
Oakwood birch wood and pine wood now
this wood can we see can be crafted into
a the assorted with planks this where
planks can be crafted in the stairs and
slabs which is awesome we also see that
we have the leather items stand for
paintings and there's a map on it also
something most people will miss in the
hot bar there's a bucket and bowls are
stackable now so that's sweet next up we
got this it's pretty simple we see
another point where items are being
displayed so we definitely know that's
the thing we got at the clock and right
in the crafting interface we can see
that you are able to craft nether bricks
which means you can craft other things
like nether stone and that's cool and at
first I thought glass planes was part of
it note but glass planes is already in
the game so you don't have to worry
about that another one we got coming up
right now boom alright this one it's not
that much but it's pretty simple I think
grab my beginning texture change i'm not
sure don't quote me but we got wooden
buttons so which is something they don't
have in the game currently no wooden
buttons can be activated by shooting an
arrow at them or anything like that so
that's really cool that's that basically
all I saw on this one lastly we have
this we got the advent we just see of
stairs of the different types of wood
and we also have sand stone stairs which
is really cool if you don't notice to
right so we got each different type of
wood stair and tents with stairs that's
basically everything I could find I hope
you guys really enjoyed this subscribe
if you're new and leave like peace